I am very excited that you use your
platform to shine a light on things that
maybe not everybody knows about well
that's how I feel about you as well yes
my manager who I've been with since I
was literally 14 years old my entire
team since I was basically 14 15 years
old so we've become very close her son
has a very rare disorder to see is
called EB EB MRF and it's very rare and
nobody really knows about it and we're
trying to get the word out about it
never heard about it most people haven't
yeah and then you see it you hear about
it and is really it's really tough and
he lives with us every single day and
this family is amazing
and we just want to find a cure for this
effin thing sooner than later and it's
coping with a rare illness that is as
tragic as it is mysterious take a look
I'm breathing I am 15 years old and I
live in Los Angeles California
I have epidermolysis bullosa which is a
skin condition that you were born with
which means a very fragile skin
basically you're missing the gene that
produces collagen which binds the layers
of the skin together Brandon wants to
participate as fully as he can and when
he has bad days and can't get out of bed
it's just it's really it's heartbreaking
and he deals with an enormous challenge
quite gracefully I think I want people
to know that like yeah it doesn't define
me and there's gonna be good days and
bad days and like I try to just fit over
the bad days and just keep hoping for
the good days we are you know amazed
every day at his ability to just wake up
and and deal as best he can and life is
tough but so is he
[Music]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this